what the hell
[Music]
looks like the whole city's under attack
we've got a report of a raid on the
Gotham PD arsenal if those bastards get
their hands on our weapons
this is coordinated its Riddler's gang
it has to be
we're gonna need Batman for this one
agreed
in episode 1 of Batman the enemy within
the tragic loss of a friend and Ally
threatened to undermine Batman's crusade
for justice while also throwing Bruce
Wayne's personal life into disarray as
someone that loves to see the duality of
DC's Dark Knight used to unravel him I
was eager to see telltale games pull out
his narrative thread but episode 2
allows it to slip away while this is
certainly a missed opportunity telltale
makes up for it by thrusting Bruce Wayne
into situations that begin to blur the
line between right and wrong and it
proves to be just as compelling the end
of the line thanks John you said you'd
kill him and after you got what you
needed
sowhat's ain't a girl allowed to change
your minds episode 2 is perhaps the
strongest indication that telltale is
done with digging up Bruce Wayne's past
trauma to torment him and more
interested in giving him new demons to
face so perhaps new is a bit of a
stretch since the villains bats goes up
against our familiar faces from his
rogues gallery mostly unchanged from the
way they've been depicted in past albeit
with one major exception Harley Quinn
who is a standout character in this
episode exhibits a drastic shift in her
power dynamic with the Joker
traditionally Harley has been depicted
as Joker's long-suffering right-hand
woman doing all the hard work but
receiving very little respect for it
she's always been infatuated with the
mentally deranged Clown Prince of Crime
even though he treats her like a
disposable tool reciprocating her love
only when it suits him telltale has
turned his dynamic on his head facing
Harley in the position of power instead
of John Doe the man the series is
setting up to become the Joker he's
still very much on the edge of his
madness yet to leap into the insanity
that transforms him as such he's still
unsure of himself and finding his way
something which Holly takes full
advantage of this time around he's the
one fawning after her and she relishes
in toying with his emotions this
subversion for longtime fans of Batman
mythos is fascinating to watch and an
interesting take on the character but
it's not just Joker that Holly has at
her beck and call with the Riddler taken
care of she assumes control of Gotham
City's cabal of new villains in episode
1 John Doe offered Bruce an opportunity
to meet his friends and under direction
from Amanda Waller to infiltrate
ranks Wain finds himself having to win
their trust this sale paves the way for
episode two his most tense and defining
moments as Bruce Wayne
you must weigh up the need to curry
favor from dangerous criminals against
the inherent risk of dealing with the
Devils
[Music]
[Music]
usually mercy that was mistake thank you
somewhere while the decisions you make
they're in generally resolved themselves
in a way that keeps the narrative on
script in the moment there's plenty of
drama in directing Bruce to attack an
innocent so that their no-goodniks trust
him he'll tell asked fans to violate the
principles they know Bruce Wayne holds
dear effectively twisting their own
image of the character the various
decision making moments in Episode two
are a very effective realization of that
classic doing something bad for the
greater good trope this sense of being
stuck between a rock and a hard place
extends to Batman's new working
relationship with Amanda Waller and the
strain it puts on his friendship with
Jim Gordon the cliffhanger in Episode
one revealed that Waller true to form
knows more about Batman than most giving
her leverage of him since her
investigation is undermining Gordon's
Batman finds himself stuck between two
people on the same side of the law but
with different objectives and approaches
again this is another instance where
telltale has set you up to either make
life harder for Bruce Wayne by siding
with Waller or betraying someone you
know is an ally to Batman this early in
the series it's difficult to say whether
these decisions will pay off in a
gratifying way but in the moment it
really sucks to have disappointed Gordon
your public persona could be of great
help to us here maybe even as much as
Batman in certain situations I
understand you think I work for you
you're not working
we're working together after all we both
want the same thing am i right
while episode 2 is filled with strong
characterization and writing one person
stands out as a weak link
Alfred's involvement in the story thus
far has been entirely forgettable
serving mostly to parrot back the events
that happened in the scene preceding his
appearance or doing the worried father
figure routine alfred is a tricky
character to make valuable especially
when Bruce is out of his moping woe is
me face when he can serve as the
emotional anchor for Batman as I via his
inclusion in the enemy within doesn't
feel justified he feels like dead weight
against the rest of the cost
episode 2 also continues to push further
away from the slower paced investigation
sequences from the first season one bomb
defusal section aside the majority of
gameplay is made up of action driven set
pieces controlled through quicktime
button presses it's a shame that
telltale seems to be playing down the
clue hunting and puzzle solving elements
featured in the first season although
this keeps the story moving at a brisk
pace those moments were key in
delivering a well-rounded Batman
experience fans that like to see the
Cerebral side of Batman are going to be
left wanting by episode 2 nevertheless
Batman the enemy within episode 2 builds
on the strong opening to the season it
raises the stakes for Bruce Wayne by
throwing him into a shark tank and
asking him to turn bloodthirsty enemies
into friends along with an empowered
Holly Quinn and the unnerving powder-keg
that is John Doe the second episode
provides drama and excitement in equal
measure
alfred probe the murder
we're going to need it
[Music]
[Music]